[Hamza] Geil!
[Kiki] Ich wusste, dass du das Wort sagst!
Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute gibt es einen Caramel Carrot Cake!
Warum hört sich auf Englisch immer alles so viel besser an?
Oder ich sag einfach: "einen Möhren-Karamellkuchen!"
[Hamza] Das hört sich voll langweilig an!
Es ist leider so! Auf Englisch hört sich alles immer cooler an!
Wir fangen jetzt direkt an mit dem saftigen Möhrenboden.
Dafür hab ich hier meine Küchenmaschine.
Ihr dürft natürlich auch gerne euer Handrührgerät benutzen aber denkt dran:
da müsst ihr immer 2-3min länger schlagen.
Es geht jetzt zu Beginn darum, die Eier richtig schön hell-cremig zu schlagen
mit 'ner Prise Salz, mit Vanilleextrakt und mit Zucker.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt wundert: "Wo stehen die ganz genauen Mengenangaben?"
[Hamza] Infobox!
[Kiki] Infobox! Wie immer.
So, während die Eiermasse 5min lang bei maximaler Geschwindigkeit richtig schön dick und hell-cremig geworden ist,
habe ich die Zeit auch genutzt um die Möhren schon mal zu schälen und zu raspeln.
Und was ich auch mache: Ich nehme mir jetzt noch Haselnüsse.
Die sind schon geröstet und die hacke ich jetzt auch nochmal fein.
Ihr könnt natürlich selber entscheiden: Nehmt ihr vielleicht Pecannüsse, Walnüsse?
Da könnt ihr komplett variieren, das ist gar kein Problem!
Und als nächstes gebe ich die trockenen Zutaten in die Eiermasse,
rühre das kurz mit der Maschine unter
und dann mache ich mit meinem Teigschaber weiter indem ich die Möhren und die Nüsse unterhebe.
Also jetzt haben wir hier erstmal Mehl und Backpulver und das braucht ihr auch gar nicht sieben,
bei dem Teig müsst ihr das nämlich gar nicht!
Das sind gemahlene Mandeln, die kommen jetzt auch noch mit dazu.
Vielleicht habt ihr gemerkt, dass oben die Mandeln bei mir heller waren als unten.
Das lag einfach daran, dass ich so ein bisschen meine Vorratsdosen ausgemistet habe
und einfach an gemahlenen Nüssen das genommen habe, was noch da ist.
Hauptsache die Grammangabe stimmt!
Ihr könntet auch gemahlene Haselnüsse z.B. nehmen,
das ist bei dem Rezept gar kein Problem.
So und jetzt will ich nicht so viel Luft rausschlagen aus dem Teig,
daher jetzt nur noch mit dem Schneebesen oder mit dem Teigschaber weitermachen.
Und das sind jetzt hier unsere saftigen Möhren.
Und da gebe ich dann noch wie gesagt die gehackten Haselnüsse dazu,
auch da könnt ihr selbst entscheiden. Ich wiederhole mich heute ziemlich oft!
Aber ich schreibe euch das ja auch immer in die Infobox was ihr da genau ersetzen könnt.
Und jetzt kommt so mein Top Tipp!
Also noch so ein kleines Schmankerl hier im Teig!
Und da gebe ich Karamelldrops mit dazu.
Ich werd sie euch in der Infobox verlinken.
[Kiki]Die sind so pur schon sehr lecker aber ich glaub -
[Hamza] Die sind wirklich gut!
Ja, auch abends mal wenn ich Quark mache, packe ich mir die rein.
Oder wenn man einfach mal Porridge macht nochmal obendrauf als Topping.
Und im Teig sind die auch nochmal sehr lecker, das hab ich nämlich ausprobiert.
Und jetzt rührt ihr das nur ganz kurz unter und den Backofen hab ich auch schon vorgeheizt,
dann wird der nämlich schon gebacken.
[Hamza] Boah, ich freu mich richtig drauf! Ich hab noch nie so einen Kuchen gegessen!
[Kiki] Der ist richtig lecker!
So, beide Teige sind jetzt 2cm hoch, das erkennt man hier ganz gut.
Die habe ich gleichmäßig verteilt und jetzt werden sie gebacken.
Den Teig habe ich jetzt gleichmäßig verteilt
und zwar auf 2 Tortenringe mit 20cm Durchmesser.
Und anschließend könnt ihr die Böden auch schon direkt in den vorgeheizten Backofen geben
bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze für 28min.
Danach vollständig zugedeckt auskühlen lassen.
Und natürlich nutzen wir die Zwischenzeit und machen jetzt Karamell selber!
Und das geht super easy indem ihr einfach einen Topf - ich nehm gern meinen..
[Hamza] Das heißt Kamarell!
[Kiki] Kamarell!
Zwei Eis mit Kamarell!
Kamarell geht ganz einfach indem ihr jetzt einen Topf oder eine Pfanne nehmt,
die sollte am besten beschichtet sein, also so funktioniert's für mich z.B. am besten.
Und da gebt ihr ganz einfach Zucker rein.
Achso, Stufe 7 von 9 einstellen!
Viele finden das immer sehr hilfreich wenn ich noch die Stufe dazu nenne,
das finde ich persönlich auch. Bei mir ist es Stufe 7 von 9.
Zucker und Wasser einmal reingeben, kurz verrühren
und dann von alleine karamellisieren lassen.
Das kann 10-15min dauern.
[Hamza] Was machst du wenn jemand 10 Stufen hat?
Wenn jemand 10 - manche haben auch 12 Stufen - dann würde ich sagen Stufe 9 von 12.
[Kiki] Das ist halt nur ne Richtlinie!
[Hamza] Und bei 10?
[Hamza] 7.5, ne? *lacht*
[Kiki] Bei 10 würde ich sagen...
[Kiki] Da würde ich auch sagen 7 von 12. 7 von 10! Nein, 7 von 10!
[Hamza] Da hab ich dich erwischt, ne?
[Kiki] Jaa, da hast du mich erwischt, ne? Joa!
So, der ganze Prozess hat jetzt ungefähr 10min bei mir gedauert.
Und ihr dürft am Ende dann auch noch einmal umrühren damit wirklich alle Zuckerkristalle auch karamellisieren.
Und als nächstes kommen noch weitere 3 Zutaten hinein.
Die erste ist Salz.
Die hebt nochmal den Geschmack und falls ihr jetzt Salted Caramel möchtet,
dann gebt gerne noch ein bisschen mehr dazu an der Stelle!
Ich bleibe jetzt beim normalen Karamell und da fehlen jetzt noch -
[Hamza] Kamarell!
[Kiki] Tschuldigung, ich verwechsel - ich bin so doof! Kamarell!
Und wenn ihr dann noch zimmerwarme Butter und lauwarme Sahne dazugebt,
dann wird das nochmal so eine richtig schöne Konsistenz geben.
Und später wollen wir ja auch, dass der Drip fest wird,
daher super wichtig, die 2 Zutaten hinzuzufügen.
Und ihr werdet sehen: Auch jetzt schäumt es wieder
und da müsst ihr einfach die ganze Zeit rühren.
Super wichtig - Das darf ich nicht vergessen, sonst ärgert ihr euch Zuhause:
Schaltet jetzt die Hitze runter auf Stufe 4 von 9.
So, an der Stelle wird das Kamarell auch richtig hart
und dann einfach weiterrühren bis es wieder flüssig wird.
[Hamza] Ja, bring den Leuten nicht was Falsches bei! Alles gut!
[Kiki] Ja nicht, dass ihr denkt ich bin doof!
So, und jetzt ist es fertig. Ich nehm's jetzt vom Herd und Vorsicht: Sehr, sehr heiß!
Lasst es auf jeden Fall herunterkühlen.
Jetzt kommt die letzte Komponente, nämlich unsere Mascarpone-Sahnecreme
mit einem Vanille-Ton.
Und dafür werde ich jetzt einfach Schlagsahne - die ist ganz kalt und frisch aus dem Kühlschrank -
in der Küchenmaschine zusammen mit Sahnefest steif schlagen.
Und parallel verrühre ich Mascarpone - die kommt auch aus dem Kühlschrank -
mit Puderzucker, welches ich vorher durchsiebe, da habe ich Angst vor Klümpchen
und gebe da noch Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Genau, das mache ich erstmal und später vereine ich beide Zutaten und dann ist die Creme auch schon fertig!
Die Creme ist fertig, ich hab mir aber schon 5 EL für die spätere Deko gesichert.
Den Rest lasse ich hier, den Dekoteil habe ich schonmal in den Kühlschrank getan
weil gerade bei solchen Cremes ist Kühlung immer super, super wichtig.
Und jetzt können wir die abgekühlten Tortenböden einmal aus dem Tortenring entfernen.
Ich nehme da immer meinen Backformlöser damit ich mir auch die Seiten nicht wegreiße.
Und dann haben wir uns grad schon Gedanken gemacht, welche Tortenplatte, welche Farbe wir benutzen.
Da hab ich mich heute mal für Gold entschieden.
Das hat auch schon so einen kleinen Karamellton.
Auf deine Verantwortung Hamza weil ich weiß nicht, ob's farblich so gut aussehen wird!
[Hamza] Ich find das sieht schick aus!
[Kiki] Aber Hamza hatte bis jetzt immer den richtigen Riecher bei Tortenplatten!
[Hamza] Das sieht gut aus mit dem Karamell auch zusammen, das wird Kontrast -
[Kiki] Karamell, ja!
So, ich lege jetzt einen Tortenring nochmal drumherum, ich mach den jetzt auch nicht sauber.
Das braucht ihr nicht, das spare ich mir jetzt einfach.
[Hamza] Und dann wird geschichtet, ne?
[Kiki] Und dann wird geschichtet!
So, ich hab das jetzt gleichmäßig geschichtet.
Achtet darauf, dass ihr noch ein bisschen was für die äußere Schicht übrig lasst
und nicht alles verbraucht. Aber ihr solltet in der Regel auch genug Creme übrig haben.
So, jetzt hat der Tortenring schon seinen Zweck erfüllt,
es ist alles schön gerade eingestrichen.
Jetzt entferne ich den schon direkt, ihr müsst ihn jetzt auch an der Stelle noch nicht kühlen.
So und dann erstmal mit der restlichen Creme den äußeren Rand einstreichen.
Und anschließend für 30min in den Kühlschrank geben bevor wir dann den Drip machen.
Nach der Kühlzeit können wir jetzt sorglos unseren Drip draufgeben.
Davor fand ich dadurch, dass wir jetzt auch auf Zimmertemperatur mit der Creme gearbeitet haben,
war sie noch ein bisschen zu weich.
Aber jetzt dürfte es kein Problem sein.
Der Drip ist auch richtig schön eingedickt.
Den gebe ich jetzt drauf und dann verteilt ihr das einfach mit 'ner Winkelpalette
und lasst das an den Seiten runterfließen.
Mir kam auch gerade noch ne Idee, das hast du gar nicht mitbekommen Hamza!
Und zwar habe ich mir weiße Kuvertüre in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen
bei geringer Wattzahl, dass ihr euch nicht verbrennt.
Und da gebe ich jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen Kokosöl rein.
Und ich hoffe ich versau mir die Torte nicht!
Ich versuch's einfach! Ich hab nämlich die Idee,
da so 'ne schöne Deko noch reinzuspritzen.
[Hamza] Okay, ich bin mal gespannt!
[Kiki] Ich auch!
Ich muss aufpassen! Nicht, dass ich mir die versau!
Weil ich find sie jetzt grade einfach richtig schön!
[Hamza] Ah, dat kriegste hin Kiki!
[Kiki] Ja!
Okay, ich hab mich jetzt dazu entschieden weil ich das so hübsch finde,
dass ich die Creme nicht mehr als Tupfer jetzt nochmal on top spritze.
Eigentlich war der Plan, einfach nur den Karamellguss und dann die Tupfer obendrauf zu machen
und dann vielleicht noch was in Form von Haselnüssen oder so.
Aber ich lasse das jetzt so und zum allerersten Mal muss ich dann meine Creme ein wenig verändern
bzw. ich reduziere die Menge so, dass ihr das eben nicht mehr übrig habt
und dass die Creme dann bei euch Zuhause perfekt reicht und ihr eben keinen Überschuss oder so habt.
Weil das ist jetzt so spontan gekommen und das gefällt mir einfach richtig, richtig gut!
Also gut, der Drip hat den Boden berührt!
Das ist eigentlich ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, dass es nicht so ist! Aber -
[Hamza] Ich find das hat einen guten Look irgendwie!
[Kiki] Hat was!
[Kiki] Es hat was!
[Hamza] Ich find das hat einen richtigen Drip Look!
Ja, ich find es hat was! Es ist ja kein gewöhnlicher Drip.
Da ist ja keine Schokolade drin, die dann irgendwie fest wird oder so, sondern Karamell Drip!
Also mir gefällt er sehr, sehr gut! Ich lass den jetzt noch kühlen.
Ihr könnt den jetzt ungefähr ½h kühlen nochmal
oder je nachdem, wie kalt der Kühlschrank eingestellt ist, auch 1h,
dann wird das oben auch nochmal etwas fester.
Und ich verabschiede mich an der Stelle, ihr dürft aber noch nicht ausschalten!
Denn es gibt später noch Hamza's berühmten Taste Test am Tasty Table.
Und ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
und sage: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
[Hamza] Ich bin sowas von gespannt auf den Kuchen! Sowas von!
[Kiki] Und ich auf deine Reaktion!
[Hamza] Weil ich find das sieht aus wie Trilece!
[Kiki] Boah, das haben so viele geschrieben auf Instagram!
[Hamza] Also Trilece als runder Kuchen ist schon cool glaube ich, oder?
[Kiki] Ja! Sollen wir mal machen?
[Hamza] So ein bisschen höher? Kann man machen, vielleicht zur Ramadan Reihe!
[Hamza] Aber das ist jetzt natürlich Carrot Camarel - Caramel?
[Kiki] Caramel Carrot Cake!
[Hamza] Ich hab's schon wegen Kamarell gesagt, deswegen!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] So, probieren wir mal! Probieren wir das Ganze mal!
[Hamza] Und übrigens: Ich hab grade hier mein Gesicht gewaschen, deswegen!
[Kiki] lacht
[Hamza] So, ich hab jetzt glaub ich alles drauf, ne? Das fühlt sich schon so richtig knusprig an! So crunchy!
[Kiki] Okay! Boah, ich bin so gespannt! Ich hab nämlich grad auch schon probiert!
[Hamza] Geil!
[Kiki] Ich wusste, dass du das Wort sagst! Ich wusste, dass das deine Reaktion ist!
[Hamza] Boah, das harmoniert so geil zusammen! Dieses Karamell - Kamarell und Karotten. Ich hätt's nicht gedacht!
[Hamza] Also ich hab schonmal diesen Carrot Cake gegessen von Starbucks, den du mal gemacht hast, ne?
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Hamza] Und da war ich auch fasziniert weil ich hab noch nie 'nen Karottenkuchen gegessen.
[Hamza] Und wenn ich jetzt den probiere mit Kama - mit Karamell..
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Mit Karamell - Das schmeckt schon, das harmoniert richtig gut! Wirklich sehr, sehr geil!
[Kiki] Vielleicht kannst du noch zu den Haselnüssen, zu den Drops, zu der Creme..
[Kiki] ...dass die Creme auch sehr vanillig-lecker dazu passt?
[Hamza] Man merkt sofort: Du hast Karamell Drops drin!
[Hamza] Ich hab's direkt rausgeschmeckt! Richtig crunchy, knusprig.. gerade auch mit den Nüssen.
[Kiki] Und wie ist der Teig so damit die Zuschauer sich das vorstellen können? Beschreib den mal!
[Kiki] Ich glaub viele wären grad an deiner Stelle!
[Hamza] Das wollt ich gerade sagen: Der Teig ist relativ feucht.
[Hamza] Und so, so weich halt! Nicht so trocken oder so.
[Kiki] Ja, durch die Möhren!
[Hamza] Man merkt das auf jeden Fall. Da steckt sehr viel Liebe in dem Kuchen.
[Hamza] Also wenn ich das im Laden kaufen würde, ich würde sagen 4,50€ - 5€, ganz ehrlich!
[Kiki] Boah, ja!
[Hamza] Aber das ist es dann auch wert!
[Hamza] "Boah ich will den Carrot Cake probieren!" Gehst du da rein, kriegst du den Kuchen serviert,
[Hamza] ..denkst du dir: "Boah, 5€ hat sich gelohnt!" Ehrlich!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Mega lecker, Leute macht's unbedingt nach!
[Hamza] Die Creme in der Mitte macht's nochmal aus find ich!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Also da ist nochmal so 'ne richtig sahnige Note drin!
[Hamza] Und es sieht echt toll aus, wirklich! Auch von der Optik her!
[Hamza] Wenn ihr das so schön hinbekommt wie Kiki, dann habt ihr alles..
[Kiki] Jaa, das kriegen die locker hin!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall!
[Hamza] Kiki... gemeistert! Auf jeden Fall!
[Hamza] Leute, nachmachen! Abonnieren, liken..
[Hamza] Folgt auch meinem Vlog Kanal weil da verpasst ihr auch keine Videos!
[Kiki] Hey, einfach Werbung machen hier! Unverschämtheit!
[Hamza] Ich bring ja jede Woche einen Vlog raus hinter den Kulissen.
[Hamza] Peace and out! Kiki, echt lecker, wallah!